[Music]
my take on it is I like to put out
positive energy and I like to be able to
maintain a compassionate approach to
this because people try these diets
because they want results and they feel
frustrated with what they've currently
got I remember myself I I did low carb
for a while thinking it was best for me
and I got results and I looked good and
so I thought well of course this is the
way forward so I can completely
understand where people are coming from
with regard to this on the same with
keto people go on keto diets to get
results or to feel better and I'm not
gonna be in a position where I deny
people's personal experience but I am
gonna be in a position where I share
information both on long-term health and
short-term health outcomes so that they
can then hopefully come to a decision
based on rationality over what someone
told them once on the internet that's
dr. Gemma Newman and this is the retro
podcast
[Music]
the rich roll podcast hey everybody how
you guys doing what's happening my name
is rich roll I'm your host this is my
podcast welcome or welcome back today we
have a fun conversation an informative
immersive conversation a participatory
conversation that we recorded during our
recent retreat in Italy it's with the
lovely the delightful the whip-smart
uk-based plant power doctor herself dr.
Jemma Newman what's interesting about
Gemma is that she isn't an ideologue she
didn't arrive upon her conclusions
around plant-based eating by way of some
kind of moral or ethical compunction but
rather by hard science and self
experimentation as a young doctor a
recent med school graduate she like many
newly minted physicians had been
neglecting her own health for some time
she was struggling with her weight and
thus went on this journey
she tries a low carb diet having bought
into the background hum of cut the carbs
and all sugar is bad she'd also read
some research around intermittent
fasting she begins calorie counting and
carb restriction she does an hour of
exercise every single day and it worked
I mean sort of she found herself going
from size 18 to a size 8 lost a bunch of
weight and feeling I guess a little bit
smug she then goes and checks her blood
profile and discovers that her lipid
panel was significantly raised and she
knew being a doctor that having a raised
cholesterol and LDL were both markers
suggesting a tendency to heart disease
and this is something that runs in her
family both her father and her
grandfather died relatively young of
arthrosclerosis
but she just sort of chalked it up to
being a genetic marker in the wake of
all of this gemma is offered a book deal
to tell her story to kind of share her
weight loss secrets
but something just didn't feel right to
her she couldn't do it she didn't feel
like she was a nutrition expert and even
though she looked healthy on the outside
this lipid profile issue was really kind
of nagging at her in the back of her
mind and she wanted to be able to share
an opinion based on research as well as
her personal experience so she turns
down the book deal a story with Gemma
continues and I'm gonna tell you a
little bit more about her and all that
in a minute but first today's episode is
brought to you by a brand new sponsor
super excited about these guys Grove
collaborative look people healthy
plant-based non-toxic cleaning products
work point blank
and the good ones are actually more
enjoyable to use and more accessible and
available to you than you might think
they're better for you they're better
for the planet
but where do you start who do you trust
well that's where Grove collaborative
comes in Grove collaborative is the
online marketplace that delivers all
natural home beauty and personal care
products directly to you Grove takes the
guesswork out of going green and every
Grove dot Co product is guaranteed to be
good for you your family your home the
planet so you can save time reading
confusing labels Julie and I just got
our first shipment from Grove
collaborative last week and it was such
a convenience not having to shop at
multiple stores or search endlessly
online to get the natural good products
that we love for our house and we try to
be as mindful as we can when we're
picking products for our space but
sometimes you go to one store they don't
have it you got to go to the other one
they don't have it either and you kind
of give up but Grove they make what was
once a chore really simple so join me
and over a half a million families who
trust Grove collaborative to make their
homes happier and healthier plus
shipping is fast and free on your first
order for a limited time when my
listeners go to Grove co.com Grove dot
Co slash rich roll you'll get a free
five piece spring cleaning set from mrs.
Myers and Grove which has a $30 value go
to grove dot co rich roll to get this
exclusive offer grove dot co slash rich
roll today's episode is also brought to
you by outturn own a
amazing clothes created sustainably good
for you good for the planet
look finding high quality clothes that
fit isn't always easy finding high
quality sustainably made clothes that
fit and look cool that's a tall order
that can be straight-up hard but not
without her known founded by pro surfer
and 11 time world champion Kelly Slater
you know this guy right outter known is
on a mission to create awesome clothes
that don't harm the planet if you're a
regular listener to the show then you
know I've had guests like Joshua catcher
and filmmaker Andrew Morgan both of whom
have come on the show to talk about just
how awful the fashion industry is for
the earth conventional cotton farming is
responsible for 25% of the world's total
pesticide use and denim which we all
wear is one of the filthiest
manufacturing processes that exists in
apparel but outturn own transcends all
of this they transcend the polluted
waters of modern garment making and
their manufacturers have come up with
this methodology these procedures to
make incredibly comfortable jeans their
SCA genes in the world's cleanest
solar-powered denim factory where 98% of
the water used in development is
actually recycled and the other 2% is
used to build bricks which is incredible
and they even air dry their products to
save energy and they don't stop there
outter known only uses organic cotton
which conserves 90 percent more water
compared to conventional cotton the
clothes are incredible I mean everything
down to their buttons which are made
from recycled ocean plastics are
consciously crafted with our planet and
people in mind our noun of course only
works with factories that pay fair
living wages and provides safe working
conditions and to top it off the clothes
are cool I'm wearing one of their pairs
of SCA jeans right now and they're super
comfortable they're beautifully made
they're fashionable I am walking around
in proof that you don't have to harm the
environment to have badass clothes but
you don't have to take my word for it
you got to try out or known for yourself
so go to outer known comm today and
enter my code rich roll a check out and
you'll get 25% off your full price order
outter known Oh ute are KN o w and.com
check out their sustainable selection of
men's and women's apparel and don't
forget to use the promo code rich roll
for 25% off so you guys know that we
have this plant power meal planner
digital platform and I wanted to take a
minute to kind of share a perspective
about it for those of you who are new to
the show if you're struggling with your
diet which is great that you've turned
into this episode because it's all about
that if you're really desiring of
mastering your plate but you feel like I
don't have the time I don't know if the
budget I don't really know how to cook
all that well I really think that our
plant power meal planner program
platform can really help you because we
created it to solve one very simple
problem how do you make nutritious
eating convenient delicious and
affordable when you sign up at meals
rich Volcom you get access to thousands
of delicious easy to prepare plant-based
recipes that are totally customized
based on your personal preferences we
have unlimited grocery lists that are
automatically developed when you select
the recipes that you like and it
integrates with grocery delivery in most
metropolitan areas so all the things
that you need to make the recipes just
magically show up at your door we also
have an incredible team of nutrition
coaches at the ready seven days a week
to answer all of your questions and we
offer this for just one dollar and
ninety cents a week when you sign up for
a year which is an incredible deal it's
literally a price of a cup of coffee to
learn more you can go to meals rich
Volcom or click on meal planner on the
top menu on our website and we recently
pulled everybody who's using the product
and we got some really incredible
results from our survey that I wanted to
share with you first of all 76 percent
of all users say that the plant power
meal planner has given them better
health outcomes than other diets that's
amazing ninety-eight percent of users
say they prefer the plant power meal
planner over any other diet they've
tried and all of these people who were
polled
have tried at least one other diet 86%
of users have increased their fruit and
veggie consumption by at least one
serving 79 percent have increased their
fruit and vegetable intake by two or
more serve
and 50% have increased their fruit and
vegetable intake by three or more
servings per day we all know how
important that is and here's a little
feedback from some of the users one
person said it has simplified my
plant-based eating and reduced my
grocery budget that's a win somebody
else said quote more energy better
control over hormones generally happier
less stressed I was at the point where
all I was doing was dieting and my
relationship with food was purely
negative biggest thing for me is that I
don't feel hungry I was always feeling
hungry before and I think it was because
I wasn't meeting my body's needs way
better self control less cravings that I
can't describe I'm able to enjoy food
again
end quote what else can you ask for it
right like I said super proud of this
product I really recommend anybody who's
struggling in this area check it out so
again go to meals rich roll calm or
click on meal planner on the top menu on
my website okay
so here we have Gemma she's struggling
with this conundrum slimming down
low-carb style yet facing unfortunate
lipid panels and kind of struggling
grappling with what to do and around the
same time her husband Richard he was a
great guy by the way
picked up a little book called finding
ultra while training for the London
Marathon and decided that he was going
to give this whole plant-based diet a
try
and now Gemma on the other hand being
the sceptical doctor that she is coming
out of a very traditional educational
background was let's just say not
exactly happy about this she was a
little irritated maybe perhaps a little
shocked where is he gonna get his
protein won't there be nutritional
deficiencies we'll never be invited to a
friend's house for dinner ever again how
will I feed my family these were her
fears not necessarily in that order but
her husband was undeterred and this guy
Richard ends up running his next
marathon an incredible 1 hour and 10
minutes faster than his previous time
now this got Gemma's attention she'd
already been passionate about
researching lifestyle medicine and how
changes in things like stress and sleep
exercise diet could improve health for a
long time but nothing really prepared
her for the powerful transformations
that were possible when people embrace
the whole food plant-based diet so she
starts looking into it more deeply she
starts experimenting on herself and the
results of which we're going to explore
today again this is a live recording and
it also includes a really great Q&A with
the amazing guest that joined us this
year for our retreat in Italy really
special bunch of people I thoroughly
enjoyed this conversation with Gemma her
second retreat with us along with her
husband Richard so let's talk to her
this is me and dr. Gemma Newman
[Music]
so last year on this day we had the
happy pair guys here and it was similar
they did a demo and then they came in
here to do a podcast and we were sitting
on this couch and they were literally
like sitting in each other's laps I was
like could you guys be more conjoined as
a singular human but it worked
it always does with them so over the
last couple days we have explored many
themes and topics we have probed our
minds we've done yoga we've been trail
running meditation we traveled two
portals unknown beyond Westeros through
holotropic breathing and everything in
between
and as you might gather today is more of
a food diet and nutrition themed sort of
experience we had our food demo with the
lads and I thought this would make for
an appropriate moment to have Gemma come
on not just the podcast but to share
with all of you guys here today a little
bit about her experience with diet and
nutrition from a medical point of view
from a medical perspective so we're
gonna talk about all things plant-based
are you up for it I'm well and truly
ready that good I don't wait well first
of all how what is the kind of landscape
or you know temperature currently in the
UK in terms of like the plant-based
lifestyle and how people are perceiving
it and practicing it I think it's really
mixed and there are some areas of
Medicine that are kind of really
switched on like we've got the
plant-based health professionals UK and
they are I'm an advisory board member
for them and they're really helping to
promote a plant-based lifestyle for
health longevity and no planetary health
as well and then you've got the other
sort of contingent where I've got the
whole diet Wars thing going on you know
you got those low-carb airs and you've
got the Palio's and you've got the key
toes so my aim
in cutting through all that is to just
think what do people actually really
need to know and what they really need
to know at this point is that we're
eating more than 50% ultra-processed
foods the national diet nutrition survey
in the UK tells us that there's only an
eight percent fruit and vegetable intake
in the UK that's what we are eating and
so when you look at those basic facts
you think what's the point in arguing
amongst ourselves we need to get people
to understand that Whole Foods fruits
vegetables whole grains beans lentils
chickpeas oats all those kinds of foods
herbs and spices that is the cornerstone
of health and the one else can argue
over the other bits and pieces but it's
a bit like David Katz at the true health
initiative you know he really tried to
get all the nutrition experts dieticians
really focused on what do people
actually need to know and that's what I
always try to focus on what and where is
the consensus amongst professionals
across a variety of disciplines and
specialties the consensus on the whole
is fruit and veg are good we can all
share coming from the carnivore
perspective Ison yes
yeah if you're a carnivore then though
obviously but that's a whole new level
of crazy
yeah well that eight percent statistic
do you know if that's higher or lower in
the United States I don't know but I
would imagine it's similar and probably
slightly lower even because it does seem
to be that there's a bigger
preponderance of ultra-processed foods
here and many people don't even know
what ultra-processed means you know when
I say the word ultra process then
they'll think what does that mean it's
basically why don't ya define it yeah so
when you go into a store you have a look
and see okay where the packaged cakes
where the packaged breads all the ready
meals that aren't made with whole fresh
ingredients that's essentially what an
ultra processed food is you know you get
these little cupcakes and cookies and
crisps and chips and those kinds of
foods that's all ultra processed and
some people that's all they live on in
the United States a big kind of driving
contributor to that is socio-economic
there's a lot of people who are living
in food deserts they're on food stamps
their access to fresh produce is limited
and there's a cost barrier in many cases
and this is kind of further driving that
too
and making the people who are most in
need of health the least healthy is it
similar in the UK
yes it's similar but it's not quite so
bad in that respect we have a benefit
system and we have various supermarkets
that are within reach for all people
having said that there are still
financial constraints for a lot of
people and I spoke with a dietician
recently she was heading up the blue dot
campaign which is in the UK and it's
basically helping people to understand
about planetary health and making sure
that they're making choices for their
physical health and the health for
future generations
and people who are on the bread line
they don't necessarily want to hear
about that but actually this dietician I
spoke with who's working with people
who've just got out of prison working
with people who are very low
socioeconomic status helping them to
understand that actually a diet
sensitive how fruits vegetables whole
grains and beans can be incredibly
incredibly cheap if you know where to
look and if you know how to cook and
that's the other barrier is actually
knowing how to cook in the first place
so that's what she's working on it she's
doing some really good work there mm-hmm
so your practice is your general
practitioner yeah absolutely correct but
you have that all these like sub
specialties I mean you've had experience
in a wide variety of disciplines in your
medical career yeah I have and I chose
to specialize in general ism because I
realized that that was probably the most
effective way of getting people from
cradle to grave
gradually slowly getting to know them
making those bit-by-bit changes because
the system in the UK is quite different
although they're still the same
pressures we've only got 10 minutes lots
so you have to be fairly fairly
disciplined and how you spend that time
they come in they've got their own
expectations of what they're going to
get from you
you got your expectations of what you
think they need and then you've got to
marry that with what they think they
need and what they actually need in your
opinion and then you try and bring it
all together in 10 minutes and come up
with something that will be useful to
them but it's I like to think of it as a
little bit like saving lives in slow
motion because you have the time over
several consultations when you know
families and you know you know lots of
different people in that in that family
and friend group to gradually chip away
and
give them a few ideas here and there and
it's a really rewarding job I wouldn't
have chosen any other specialty because
it's the only one that I've found where
you know you can really get to know
people and where did the the diet and
lifestyle component of your practice
begin to you know enter into the
equation for you well you know like most
enthusiastic young medics I wanted to
help people you know that's why most go
into medicine and so lifestyle was
always pretty important to me but as a
young as a young graduate I didn't look
after myself oh I just ate what I was
used to eating and I didn't me think
much about it I wasn't ill myself so I
mean you weren't like exercising and
eating super healthy while you were you
know handling some crazy medical school
curriculum until like 4:00 in the
morning and on these 72 hour shifts
where they don't let you sleep so I
ended up getting I ended up getting
obese I had a high blood pressure I had
high cholesterol and I felt a bit
hypocritical because I knew that I was
going to be in a position where I'd have
to help people make some drastic life
changes and I wasn't doing that myself
so my first foray into the world of
lifestyle medicine was thinking okay
well I need to lose weight I need to get
fit I need to get healthy so I just
turned to popular culture as most
doctors do unfortunately in terms of
nutrition at least and I went on a
low-carb diet and I started calorie
counting and I started exercising for an
hour a day and I got fairly rigorous
with it and I gone I went from a size 18
to a size eight which I think in the
u.s. is 14 to a 4 something like that
anyway I worked very hard I was really
kind of smug then I thought oh you know
this is easy but then you know I decided
in my smugness to check my blood
profiles and I had a raised cholesterol
and lipid profile still and I kind of
had to eat a bit of humble pie exhort
okay maybe this is just my genetic
heritage maybe this is never gonna
change for me because my grandfather had
already died of heart disease and I
didn't know it back then but my father
was also gonna die suddenly of heart
disease in his late 50s not overweight
so anyway I can't
forgot about it and just thought oh well
just gonna have to live and do what I do
until my husband around the London
Marathon mm-hm and for him he wanted to
do something good he wanted a good time
but he was getting injuries all the time
he kept on getting inflamed feet and
ankles and hips and had to stop training
and he was quite disappointed with
himself he thought okay next year I'm
gonna do better and so he started
looking for inspiration and he looked at
your book finding ultra sorry about that
and he also read Brendan Fraser's work
you know the guy that made Wolverine
like really really buff and I think
Scott Jurek anyway he said to me Gemma
I'm gonna go plant-based I was like
what's that what you mean you're the
doctor right take a step back for a
moment so I gather that there was no
nutritional instruction of any substance
in your medical school experience is
that we had physiology and then we had
pathophysiology of disease mostly and
communication skills and consultation
skills of various specialties and
anatomy and pharmacology so we had a
good foundation but in terms of wellness
in terms of prevention no not a great
deal at that point so yeah I thought
what does that mean to be partly said
you know I'm gonna I'm gonna go healthy
vegan I was like oh my god
we're never gonna be invited to
someone's house for dinner again ever I
was kind of quite negative about the
whole thing I thought well how long ago
was this probably about three years or
so ago maybe um maybe a bit more anyway
so he did what he was gonna do and he
ran the next marathon and he didn't have
to stop training and he was he was just
going from strength to strength as you
could probably imagine and he ran the
marathon an hour and 10 minutes faster
than the previous attempt that he had
done mm-hmm an hour and 10 minutes a
fluke oh my god completely it made no
difference whatsoever
you know he picked my interest and I
began to read and then I read more and
then I read more and then I realized
that when I read more there was even
more to read and kept on researching I
read first of all starting off with
boots but then research papers more
research papers and then I began to feel
a little bit silly to be honest with you
I just thought first might my first
thought was wine had nobody told me that
all this evidence existed yeah it's
interesting that in your own kind of
exploration of diet through you know
popular culture in order to get yourself
sorted out so that you could you know be
the person you wanted to present to your
patients that you didn't come across
this or then this came as some sort of
shock it was a huge shock to me this is
strange isn't it so I I felt stupid a
little bit and but then I thought then I
I felt like had a mission I thought this
must spread because if someone like
myself who's had years of training
didn't know this then how is anyone else
expected to know this so it became a
passion from that point but I sneakily
decided to start eating plant-based
without telling anybody because I didn't
want to lose face you know think if I
could fail and after Falls you bastard
I'm a very naughty and after four weeks
of my secret plant-based diet I tested
my blood and you know over ten years
later two kids later exercising less
than half the amount I managed to
completely normal lipid profiles and I
thought okay there's something in this I
already knew that there was because I've
done a lot of research on him but it
took that final personal experience to
kind of kick me into action and then can
I sorry can I interrupt you to ask one
question yeah it's just from you being a
scientist you have your husband's
anecdotal experience and you have these
you know and he's reading these books by
these other athletes but you're coming
from this from a different perspective
so I would imagine you're gonna you're
thinking to yourself like that's all
fine but like show me that show me the
truth here so when you did go about
looking into the research or trying to
find other resources that would kind of
meet your litmus tests yeah of proof
like what was it that you look to or
what was it that kind of tipped you over
it was a combination of mechanistic data
and epidemiology really
wanted to be able to see does this play
out on a population level and is there a
plausible mechanism by which this could
be useful and once I've been able to
tally those two together then it kind of
helped me to figure out okay there is
something in this because you know any
personal experience is going to be
useful but we will have our own
cognitive bias and that's the same for
research too that's something that we
have to be mindful of but at least if
you're trying to employ the scientific
method you have a possible plausible
mechanism and then you see does this
play out on a population level could
this play out and then when it does
again it kind of really corroborates
that point of view yeah yeah I
interrupted you though where was my flow
yeah making these dear blood lipids
I was I was jolly very happy at that
point and then I had the confidence then
to sort mention it to my family and we
had diverticulosis clearing up arthritis
clearing up recurrent dental abscess is
you know sorting themselves out I
thought okay this is this is actually
pretty powerful and then of course when
I spoke to my patients that's when the
magic really happened and I began to
understand that the power of it really
and what's interesting is I've been
talking to them at lifestyle for a long
time and I knew instinctively from my
own practice that there was much more to
health and wellness than what you put in
your mouth but never had I seen such an
easy sort of in road so that people
could actually make those changes
gradually in their own health and it was
incredible to me to see the difference
in people do you do you remember like
the first patient thank you like this is
working but like now I'm gonna see if
you know I can prescribe this but
thinking yeah well I don't know should I
do this should I not do like what
distinctly distinctly remember the first
patient I tried this on so the patient
walked into my room and he's a South
African man and he was an alpha alpha
male type you know maybe not my first
experiment you know ideally but it was
close on EKU's he walked in and he sat
down and he looked
lately distraught and he never looks
like that normally and I saw you turned
to me and he said I've been sent home
from work and I've been told not to come
back and I thought what if I let myself
in for here today because you know in UK
medicine you really have no idea what
you're gonna be getting when the patient
comes in it's literally it could be
anything and people kind of open up to
you about like crazy stuff you know
anyway I didn't know whey was gonna say
I said why what's happened what's
happened he said well I failed my work
Medical I had a spot test Medical and
they did my blood pressure and it was
180 over 100 millimeters of mercury
which is very high normal optimal be
about 120 over 80 millimeters of mercury
and they they took my license away they
have formed the DVLA which is the
regulatory body in the UK and they said
no you can't come back to work and I
should get this sorted out so here I am
and he just looked at me I was like what
we gonna do 50 56 I think he was and I
said well normally someone with the
blood pressure that high we're gonna
need to try at least three different
agents to kind of get it under control
not one not two probably three and he
said there's no way I'm doing that I
said what do you mean he said well I've
never I've never taken tablets I don't
like tablets I said God do something if
you want to go back to work
he said I'll do anything and I said
anything okay well how about we do a
really strict whole food plant-based
diet and you stopped eating your meat
your eggs your cheese and you start
eating fruits vegetables whole grains
beans lentils chickpeas and oats and
herbs and spices and he looked at me as
jaw drop to say hmm well maybe I should
take that pill I said well it's not to
you everything but I mean every no but
he was he was actually really curious
cuz he'd not heard about it either and
he was also desperate because he really
loved his job so he said okay doc I'm
gonna give this plant thing a try I
thought okay fabulous great and I gave
him some resources and off he went and I
was really wondering what happened to
him so ten days later he came back and
he had this big grin on his face he sat
down I said
so what's happened he said I bought a
blood-pressure machine up and checking
it at home I thought you might like to
see my readings I would love to see your
readings and he got them out and after
the first few days they were all
completely normal
120 over 80 millimeters of mercury and I
checked it and it was normal I'm going
back the next week checked it another
time it was normal
what about the following week checked it
a third time and at his medical and then
he went back to work and that was
actually the first time that I'd had the
the confidence to think could this be an
answer because I'd done the research
around heart disease and you know all
the benefits for reversing coronary
atherosclerosis I knew about the
lifestyle heart trial from the 90s I
knew about dr. Colville esselstyn's work
and his incredible results for people
with end-stage heart disease the Mount
Abu Heart trough from 2011 I'd done you
know I'd seen that it could work but to
actually see it in practice in real life
was just another level and it was really
fulfilling it was that was my first my
first foray how's that dude doing now
he's doing fantastically and he's still
at work and he still loves this job and
he's yeah he's managed to stick with it
this is the interesting thing
what I've noticed in my practice is that
when people get results they become the
best advocates for that way of eating
they want to share it with their family
and friends and they can't stop talking
about it and that was the case for him
he was really enthusiastic after that
well there's nothing like desperation to
fuel willingness creates the foundation
for like real change yeah but I would
imagine that that level of panic and
desperation isn't the norm and the
patients that you seek so what do you do
when someone comes to you and they're
kind of mildly in trouble but they don't
they're not they don't have that like
I'll do anything look on their face yeah
that's more of a slow burn so I'll plant
a seed and I'll see if it grows so
what's good about general practice is
that you have the opportunity to see
them again
and I had this experience of one of my
other patients actually she was in her
forties and she was she was actually
quite desperate in the end but the first
time I saw her she was kind of saying
I'm having issues with my periods and
it's not really getting better so we
talked about some of the normal things
that we would try and do for that but
then when she came back to me after
another couple of consult she said I am
desperate so I'd already mentioned the
idea of a plant-based diet and how it
might be able to help her with a
hormonal regulation yeah and I'd already
told her about the benefits of turmeric
and how to studies I read showed that it
could be as effective as an
anti-inflammatory painkiller for period
pains I'd already mentioned about how a
soy portion of soy a day could
dramatically improve flushes hormonal
flushes I'd already told her about how
East region could be
ichigen recirculation could be avoided
have a high-fiber diet east region East
region and so I'd already given her a
lot of information about and also mood
how I could have boost her mood but she
she only tried it when she got desperate
and she said look two weeks out of every
four is hell for me so I'm willing to
try it
so you allowed her that space judgment
it's a if there's a very similar thing
in in recovery community in circles
around that kind of thing it's like
someone who clearly like needs help and
you know exactly you know how to help
that person but they don't have that
willingness and you're like okay well
maybe you need to go out and do a little
more research but you know here I am you
can call me when you're ready and like
you know they it might be six months it
might be a week it might be a year but
that phone
generally rings at some point yeah
because they have to discover it for
themselves because willingness is a
self-generated thing right you can't
compel somebody to have that desire to
make that change completely and it has
to come from within and that's the case
with everybody that I see you know
they're all on their own journey and
they're all deciding what part of that
journey they're on and so it could just
be a quick conversation it could be so
what did you have for breakfast this
morning and or it could be okay so you
know have you taken up that that hobby
you mentioned to me last time just
little little pushes here and there that
that will help someone towards their
intention towards making a difference
that would then make more
fences and then create that snowball
effect to health so it's a slow process
sometimes other times it's you know like
that if they're ready for a change at
the first consult I have one chap who
was completely ready the first time I
met him and that's probably the most
profound transformations I've seen
actually so so you have you have these
experiences you know personally and
Richard your husband and that and you're
starting to see this with your patients
so obviously you're becoming more
invested in this as a viable solution
long-term how is this being received by
your peers like you're part of a
practice group right like you work with
other doctors or you're part of this you
know larger community medical community
is there was there like a what was the
response when you started telling people
like hey I'm getting great results doing
this well I'm tremendously fortunate in
that I chose a small friendly practice
and I'm a senior partner there so when I
when I chose a partner to join me I
chose somebody who was going to be open
and friendly and you know willing to
sort of listen to some of the research
that I shared with her and I've had it
overwhelmingly positive response on a
personal practice level in the wider
community there's obviously going to be
mixed responses but you know being a
member of the British society of
lifestyle medicine they are affiliated
with the American College of lifestyle
medicine and if you look at the diploma
it's all very much around the idea of a
general plant-based nutrition approach
so it's not actually something that's
necessarily controversial it's just not
widely known or accepted right so what
is I mean you said you mentioned earlier
that you never know what you're gonna
get like when somebody comes in the door
you see because you're a general
practitioner you're gonna see all
different kinds of things but I would
imagine there's a general kind of theme
in the you know the types of problems
this beetus but lets you know
restricting this to kind of chronic
lifestyle type ailments that you're
having to contend with yeah I would say
that the root cause of a lot of the
chronic disease I see
is some sort of stress response be that
physical or mental spiritual and that
can then manifest itself most commonly
with things like heart disease and
cancer and diabetes hormonal imbalances
and in children you've got the kind of
chronic respiratory infections allergies
constipation yeah and then in the
elderly we've got a rising levels of
dementia but yeah I'd say probably heart
disease number one but in terms of of
why that happens is a number of things
but the stress response I think is
something that's very much under
represented and when people lack good
food but also lack sometimes purpose or
sense of community or sense of belonging
those can really contribute to long term
disease as well that's what I've noticed
in my practice I've been in the same
place for 11 years and I see it time and
again yeah yeah just earlier today the
happy pair guys were saying look we have
there are five pillars of Health and
died nutrition are just one of those
pillars right yeah sleep and community
etc all part of like this holistic you
know equation to be truly well and you
know we have a epidemic of not just
heart disease and diabetes but mental
health disorders that are being driven
by workaholism and anxiety and stress
and all of that so when you have that
person come in who's dealing with some
you know combination of the
aforementioned in addition to like hey
maybe look at these you know dietary
protocols what are some of the other
guidelines that you kind of set for
someone like that so I I have a little
acronym I like to use and it's gloves
which is we can either take a close
close no like gloves on your hands so
you should either take your gloves off
and get your hands dirty or pita gloves
on and get to work but basically it's a
good word to use how people remember the
different things so G is I'll go through
what they mean and then I'll show you in
detail so it makes sense so gloves you
got G is
attitude L is love Oh is organic produce
V is veggies vegetables ears exercise
and SS sleep and I will aim to try to
approach one of those things as part of
one of my consultations depending on how
much time I've got with them so I mean
in terms of G the gratitude someone's
walking in and they're clearly not going
to feel much gratitude because then I
owe something wrong with me you need to
fix me but I try to explain to them look
if you're having a sense of gratitude in
your life were you trying to find things
to be grateful for
it changes your physiology and then that
also changes your disease risk and then
there was an interesting study done at a
conference in Washington last year where
they they measure people's blood levels
of cortisol and ITA
so cortisol is the stress response
hormone and IgA is one of the
immunoglobulins that we need we need to
create an immune response a beneficial
immune response to protect us against
infection and they measure them before
the conference and then during the
conference they got them to do five
minutes of gratitude exercises about
three times a day just for two days and
then they measured their blood
afterwards and they saw a significant
drop in the cortisol and they saw a
significant rise in the IgA so I I try
to kind of explain to them in terms of
physicality what an attitude of
gratitude could do for them in terms of
their current disease state and L is
loved and again that might sound a
little bit cheesy but it kind of helps
me to incorporate self-love love for
others love a community like what drives
you what is your motivation for change
what gives you meaning purpose and
intention in your life and if they can
find that then that's a really good step
towards creating a life of well-being
and that can be loads of things
basically what they're trying to do
there is activate the autonomic nervous
system and there's loads of ways of
doing that you know you could get into
journaling you could get into meditation
you could get into a hobby you could get
into a community outreach project you
could just spend five minutes dancing
around your kitchen but whatever it is
to you
find that time find that thing about one
thing that you change that week which
would then give you more of a purpose
towards moving forwards to well-being so
that's the L and then you valio organic
okay
so to me that's really important and I
understand that there are some financial
constrictions for a lot of people in
that regard and so I start out by
telling people why don't you try and get
the clean fifteen organic you know the
Environmental Working Group to clean
fifteen fruits and vegetables at least
that's a start
and the Dirty Dozen organic I mean see
about the this twelve that absorb most
pesticides those would be the organic
ones at least some people that are
listening just go to ewg org and you can
easily find those yes and they do a new
list each year don't they so but also
it's a good way of making sure that you
know you're reducing your pesticide and
your antibiotic exposure which is so
crucial for gut health which many people
are now talking about the benefits of
gut health and how important that is for
pretty much every chronic disease that
we're suffering right now so for me
that's foundational and the villa's
veggies and that includes fruit as well
fruits and vegetables because again
that's a huge cornerstone for health and
there's a lot of confusion around fruit
and whether we should be eating fruit
and the whole kind of low carb approach
to that which I can come on to later but
it's a nice reminder for people get as
many as you can in there was a study
done that showed that because in the UK
I don't know what it's like in the US
but the guidelines say about five
portions a day of fruits or vegetables
which is not nearly enough and there was
a study done recently which showed that
seven or more servings could reduce
mortality by around 42% and then there
was a lecturer Imperial that got
together 95 studies epidemiological
studies and they realized that they
didn't seem to be able to find an upper
limit of benefit for vegetable and fruit
consumption so nearing 10 portions a day
is actually potentially more optimal so
is that the big species like if somebody
comes in and says look you know I'm
trying to lose weight or trying to
tackle this whatever you know medical
condition that I have but you know III
just I can't eat fruit like fruit is
like drinking you know coca-cola or
whatever that's what I've been told so
tell me how to do this without doing
that I mean is that a common refrain and
how do you yeah well commonly people say
oh I can't eat carbs because I'm trying
to lose weight and potatoes and fruit
and not good for you so
that can be a whole new conversation
around the causes of insulin resistance
and and you know why that happens so
essentially what I try to explain to
them is that high blood sugar is the
symptom but not the cause of insulin
resistance and initially resistance
basically means that the insulin your
body is producing is not being
recognized by the cells that need to
recognize it so it's kind of floating
around the bloodstream when you've got
these glucose molecules from the food
that you're eating or floating around
the bloodstream and those glucose
molecules need to get inside the cell in
order for you to use them for energy but
they're stuck because they need that
invitation from the initially receptor
to get aside the cell so if you're
suffering from insulin resistance it
doesn't matter how many new insulin keys
your pancreas makes for you the doors
not going to unlock because the lock is
jammed and so when you remove the source
of the jammy lock so if you remove
predominantly saturated fat from the
diet from junk food and animal products
primarily then you're going to be
reducing that that jamming of the lock
and then the sugar can go directly into
the cell where it's needed for energy
and your insulin sensitivity shoots
through the roof and there's so much
research around this now researchers are
actually able to infuse free fatty acid
into people's bloodstream and watch
their insulin resistance rising and then
remove it from the bloodstream and watch
their insulin sensitivity rising so yeah
dr. Newman carbs are bad food is bad
yeah and I read a book that said I
shouldn't eat beans anymore oh yeah the
beans but let's not talk about the beans
book it's interesting cuz I think
there's any one study where they said
that someone had a bad reaction to beans
is because they were drastically
undercooked in a hospital environment
everyone else can have beans it's okay
but yeah it's it's it's a struggle
sometimes but you know what that's the
beauty of the of the of the family
physician paradigm is you can just kind
of keep looking away and you can show
them research and you can say okay how
about you meet up on this and check out
this website and come back to me let me
know what you think well we're in a very
interesting and confusing time I mean
for for generation after generation when
you had something that ale
you went to the expert to the doctor and
the doctor told you what to do and that
was like God that was not to be
questioned and you were to take that
advice then something called the
Internet happened and suddenly
information became readily available
whether it was good information or bad
information seemed to be less important
and now everybody's an expert and
everybody has an opinion and this is
something that is fueled you know in the
positive side the empowerment of people
to be more invested in their well-being
and to be in a mode of discovery all the
time and to sort of you know question
paradigms all of which I think are
healthy but at the same time it's it's
led to these silos and the kind of
consolidation of confirmation bias and
you know kind of tribal signaling and
all of this that has led to some
toxicity and confusion and when you're
dealing with medicine lives hang in the
balance
so how do you think about and
participate in kind of the discussions
either online or in person that that
have to do with this kind of diet divide
you know we call them the diet Wars
right now that are yeah there are
rampant yeah so my take on it is I like
to put out positive energy and I like to
be able to maintain a compassionate
approach to this because people try
these diets because they want results
and they feel frustrated with what
they've currently got and often times
when you know I remember myself I I did
low carb for a while thinking it was
best for me and I got results and I
looked good and so I thought well of
course this is the way forward so I can
completely understand where people are
coming from with regard to this and the
same with keto people go on keto diets
to get results or to feel better and I'm
not going to be in a position where I
deny people's personal experience but I
am going to be in a position where I
share information both on a long-term
health and short-term health outcomes so
that they can then hopefully come to a
decision based on rationality over over
what someone told them once on the
internet so the internet I think is fun
a stick I do honestly it when patients
come up to me I said oh I googled this
I'm really sorry I know you won't like
it I know I shouldn't i think actually
no i'm really glad that you did
because it shows me you have an
inquisitive mind you want to learn and
you know we can discuss this and you can
hopefully find some answers that are
going to suit your long-term health and
well-being so i I don't get involved
with the diet wars but I do like to
disseminate positive information and I
think when people are ready and willing
to receive that information then they'll
come and they'll read it and hopefully
they they will accept them what are some
of the other experiences that you've had
with patients working in this regard one
one major patient that sticks in my mind
always he had a he had a serious problem
so he was he came in to me and he was
the one that I was talking to you about
just now who I'd only seen him at one
time and I know that he'd been in and
out to see doctors many times before but
he'd never met me before and he had
prostate cancer so he'd been seen by the
urologist and they'd said to him look
it's not an aggressive type it's a
slow-growing type so we can offer you
surgery or we can kind of watch and wait
we'll see how things go if you want to
and he decided to get his PSA as
prostate specific antigen checked every
so often to make sure it wasn't going
sky-high because he was worried about
the risk of surgery and impotence okay
but he also had all of the problems he
was severely depressed he'd been
depressed for many years he had chronic
shoulder pain and tendonitis he had low
back pain and arthritis he had high
cholesterol he had high blood pressure
he was on eight different medications
strong opiate painkillers you name it he
had it and he was only in his 50s and he
was a slim man and generally you know I
felt that having seen him for the first
time he'd already been given everything
in the traditional medical model
paradigm that he could have been given
and yeah he was in tears that day he
said look I I just want something to
make me feel better the main problem for
him at that point was the pain his
arthritic pain and I thought to myself
could could a plant-based approach be
the thing that at least helps lead him
to the changes in his life could it
could it work
and I started to explain to him about
some of the studies around prostate
cancer some of the studies around
arthritis and he said what do you mean
like do you think my pain could be
improved through diet and I said well
yes I think it's really worth a good go
um so he he went away it was I'm not
sure I don't think I can do it what am I
going to make what am I gonna cook so I
did spend quite a long time within that
day normal I hope 10-minute concerts I
spent about 25 minutes which again if I
had if I had limitless time then I would
have probably spent a good two-three
hours with him talking all three but he
was at that point of desperation that we
were talking about earlier he really
wanted to change and he knew that he
tried for years on traditional lines and
hadn't got anywhere so I gave him a lot
of detailed written handwritten
information and I couldn't help but feel
for him because he has so many problems
and he came back to me several months
later and I'd wondered in the interim
what happened to him but you know you've
got so many patients you know you're
seeing 3040 people a day you can't be
ringing around people saying yeah I
haven't seen you for a while what's
going on so I hadn't contacted him but
he came back into me and I barely
recognized him and he he was he had a
huge smile on his face he said I feel
fantastic
oh wow that's great but what about the
shoulder pain you know that was really
bad he said all it's gone how much time
in elapsed 7 months 7 months had passed
and I said ok tell me about the tell me
about the back pain it's it all that's
gone as well all right ok he said I've
stopped my medications I said all right
that's great that's fantastic I said
what about your blood pit no no no
doctor you don't know something I
stopped all my medications I was like
all eight medications he said yes I said
oh right ok and then I'm panicking
thinking well you know what's his blood
results gonna be as a blood pressure got
out of control but I checked his blood
pressure which was completely normal and
he'd come in for his blood test results
that day and I was able to confirm that
his his lipid profiles were fine he
didn't need his statins and the most
powerful effect for me actually was was
being able to look at his PSA result his
prostate specific antigen because what I
realized when I saw the result was that
he'd actually managed to reverse his
prostate cancer as well using these
lifestyle changes
and when I told him the result he was he
was in floods of tears and he
immediately called his daughter to tell
her the good news and it's things like
that that really create a huge powerful
effect in me in terms of my medical
practice because it gives me a sense of
meaning and purpose to continue but also
you know it's life-changing
this is this is life or death and you
know I don't think family physicians I
don't think that they realize how how
much difference they can make if they've
got the right tools and we're all we all
go into medicine to help we all go in
because we care about people and often
maybe we get a little bit jaded thinking
there's nothing more I can do I've used
up everything in my toolbox but if you
keep filling up your toolbox then you
know you find something like plant-based
nutrition which can be hugely powerful
yeah I mean that's amazing you know I
think that that that what happens and I
say this is a total outsider
you know observational list is that
you're correct that people go into
medicine well intent they go in because
they want to help people right they're
well-intentioned and you know it's a
very laudable thing to do but there's a
system in place that wears people down
and creates that cynicism and you kind
of referenced one aspect of it which is
that 10-minute window that you get with
a patient like what can you do with that
other than try to quickly diagnose and
prescribe and I don't know what the
differences are in the UK versus the
United States but in the United States
right now we're seeing the rise of these
functional medicine clinics who are
trying to create a new paradigm outside
of that you know 10 15 20 minute window
whatever it is to try to treat patients
in a more holistic you know 360 degree
way but it sounds like you're trying to
do that while still within the structure
that that limited structure right which
has to be challenging I would imagine
that's what I'm trying to do yeah and I
understand our functional medicine
paradigm has been quite useful for if
nothing else for really helping somebody
be clearly heard and understood and
looking at many different aspects not
just medications and prescribing but
actually how much are they sleeping how
much are they moving
what toxins may they have been you know
in contact with but for me at the moment
you know
and for as long as I've been practicing
my passion has been to help people who
may not otherwise see the data may not
otherwise look online so it's kind of a
surprise to them when they come in so
clinic and they see me because they're
not they're not expecting that sort of
lifestyle approach just expected me to
you know give him another no but that's
for me that's where the magic happens is
because these people they wouldn't be
able to afford to see a functional
medicine practitioner is it the cost a
lot of money and they'll be giving out a
variety of supplements which they
wouldn't be able to afford or maintain
and so for me I want to make this
accessible for everybody
I want every single person at every kind
of financial situation to be able to
understand simple things that they can
do to improve their health and improve
their well-being and that can include
food it can include intention it can
include the purpose meaning exercise
sleep all that stuff and that stuff's
you know a lot of that stuff is free or
very cheap right right well the and the
information also is not you know often
it's already you know ret it's not just
readily available it's understood like
some of these things are common sense
right so there's this gap between
information and understanding and
actually practicing it and and it seems
that you know going back to this
discussion around the systemic
limitations you know a big part of
trying to promote adaptability long term
is accountability right like having
having programs in place with your
practice like health coaches or whatever
who are checking in on these people how
were you doing do you have questions
like if somebody gonna just you're gonna
send them off and say okay you need to
meditate and you need to do this and you
need to do that and they're like they've
just been going to you know whatever the
UK's version of Burger King is or what
out you know for they're just gonna be
able to like you know adapt and do it in
in in the manner in which you're
prescribing is pretty limited right like
so that goes like functional medicine
clinics can have those kinds of
personnel and you know I know
sure yeah right in here yes so Brendan
works with dr. Ross Feld Robert Oz
fellow who does have people that kind of
check in right and kind of keep you on
track and
countable that's wonderful and that's a
wonderful resource to have and it's also
yeah right I know dr. oz felt he's
lovely he's such a nice guy and yeah I
think that's that's wonderful it's a
it's a lovely future for the healthcare
model and I'd love to see that available
for everybody that's that would be my
ideal is that everybody could access
that and we don't have the same the same
insurance systems as you do in the u.s.
yeah it's a nationalized service that's
the other big thing like getting
insurance to cover all of this exactly
it's what changes it all yeah yeah so
that's what changes the paradigm in the
u.s. it's being able to get it kinda get
that in your Medicare yeah but in the UK
it's it's we have this basic system
where things are protocol driven and
financially driven which in a sense is a
good thing because for example the
pharmaceutical companies can't advertise
direct-to-consumer in the UK and they
also have to desert there's an element
of competition between the different
pharmaceutical companies and what drugs
that they're able to prescribe or at
least they're able to promote for
doctors to prescribe in the UK they have
to be they have to be efficient in terms
of finances so that's that's a good
thing I think in terms of keeping the
costs down but we don't have a medical
system I think that's going to be able
to cope with the rate of chronic
diseases that we're now experiencing you
know Western medical system that I have
seen is going to be able to cope with
the current rates of chronic disease
that we now have and that's where I
think a massive shift needs to take
place which is why I want to try and
make this information ready for
everybody to use eating organic eating
fruits eating vegetables you know
no-till agriculture restorative
agriculture these are the things that
are actually going to change the world
and hopefully you know change people's
lives but yeah yeah trying to make that
well the happy pair guys met with Prince
Charles they did yesterday or the day
before who I guess is super end of like
regenerative oh yeah I think you must be
he loves his plants
well now your your you know you're like
the plant-based doctor I am wondering
whether they're like people are like
don't go to dr. Newman she's gonna tell
you to go vegan it's funny I know I do I
don't expect all my patients to go vegan
because there's that big there's that
big emotional barrier for a lot of
people but I do promote plants yes I
think I say most most nutrition experts
and dietitians and physicians around the
world hopefully would also do the same
so for me it's just about making sure
that they get the education they
understand where their food is coming
from as low on the food chain as
possible eliminate sources of
antibiotics pesticides and toxins and
just eat with joy yeah and you know not
everybody's gonna go vegan but my hope
is that but more people will eat a whole
food plant-based diet and feel good and
as a result spread that message well I
feel like there's a really vibrant
growing community in at least the London
area who's super into this there's so
many there's so many young people are
into it and you know so many restaurants
and you know I attended that thing that
you put on last year for you know you're
doing like panels with all these you
know yeah medical professionals in this
area and you're there well attended and
plant-based news is in London like
there's a lot happening you know in the
UK and this movement there is and there
is momentum being gained and there is a
lot of excitement and there has to be
you know this is an exciting time we're
changing the paradigm a little bit on
what people think we have to be and the
time is now and we are in the middle of
the sixth great extinction we have to do
something now so young people are hugely
receptive to that message because they
understand it's their future and the
future of their children that's at stake
here so pun not intended do they do the
the ethical and environmental
considerations play into how you think
about all of this or you just try to
keep it on the health tip with my
patients I try to keep it on the health
because I think that that's a that's my
most important message to them but when
people are taking this way of eating on
board for their own reasons so say for
example somebody is hugely
passionate about animal advocacy and
they want to live a healthy life and be
a good advocate so that's where I help
them say okay well this is how you do it
really healthily you know you have a
whole food plant-based diet you don't go
along and have all those chips and Oreos
you know because you're not going to be
doing yourself all the animals any
favors if you do that and you know
likewise I've got patients who are
Millennials and they've done their
research around climate change and
they've been reading up on the planetary
health report and all the journals that
come out from Oxford University about
climate change and they're really clued
up and so for people like that
their passion is clear and I just want
to make sure that they do this as
healthily as possible so that they can
keep going with that passion so yeah I
want to open this up to everybody so
that you know everybody has a chance to
ask their kind of questions around
Gemma's expertise and make this more
inclusive but before we do that I think
I want to kick it off with one question
that I have which is and I get this a
lot like rich you know I love what
you're doing and your lifestyle C's
seems amazing but I go online and
there's so many health you know quote
unquote professionals or experts who are
saying all different manner of things
and it all seems to contradict each each
other like you reference you know
low-carb keto you know fruitarian raw
vegan carnivore it's like really hard
for even the most well-intentioned you
know intelligent consumer to make sense
of because everybody seems
well-intentioned and they all seem very
passionate about what they're saying and
you know how many people are gonna go on
PubMed you know a and then read past the
you know the the little summary or what
up to really is like no one's gonna do
that right so we're relying on all of
you to try to provide us with guidance
and the facts but it's becoming
increasingly more and more difficult to
really figure out what's real and what
isn't I know I feel for you rich
I feel for you I just refer people to
more like you and and I'll be honest I
think most doctors don't go on PubMed
and repass the abstracts this is this is
partly why we have a big problem is that
people who have medical credentials
don't necessarily read the whole paper
and or they may represent the paper so
all I can say is based on the evidence
that I have read from mechanistic data
from cellular longevity from
epidemiology making plants the basis of
your diet is key for microbial health
and beyond so I think it's interesting
because when people do well for example
on the ketogenic diet I don't want to
discount their experience I think to
myself well why is it why is it that
they are doing well at this point and
what's interesting to me is that a lot
of it does seem to stem from gut health
so if somebody has something like small
intestinal bacterial overgrowth or a
leaky gut then it's going to be very
difficult for them to tolerate these
healthy vibrant foods that are so common
in a plant-based diet and so maybe they
do feel a little bit better to start
with but of course if they then try to
eat these healthy foods in the future
then they've made their underlying issue
worse and so my aim in speaking with
patients is always to come at it with
empathy and compassion like what has
made you do this way of eating and how
do you feel now and then take it from
there and gut healing I think is one of
the major things that people need to do
when they when they are starting on this
journey if they've got gash intestinal
issues and things like quercetin and
glutamate and restore gut health by the
fabulous doctors at Bush as well as you
know gradually reintroducing fodmap
foods fermentable foods that
tremendously healthy but may cause
initial bloating or discomfort so it
really depends on where they're coming
from and where they're at bottom line is
a plant-based diet is the only one
that's been proven to reverse heart
disease and it's been proven to be very
beneficial for people suffering from a
variety of different cancers and we have
great mechanistic data to show why that
might be possible so I have every
confidence in recommending a
predominately plant-based diet
and then what they do with that it's up
to them but yeah in terms of things like
keto part of the reason that they might
be feeling good on it initially is
because it's quite an effective way of
regenerating mitochondria they're a
little bit tired and worn out by the pgc
went out of the pathway so I think she
said well how else how else can you
regenerate your mitochondria and there's
plenty of ways of doing that that don't
involve a high meat consumption in fact
if you are eating a lot of meat on a
keto diet you're probably doing it wrong
because you're getting too much protein
when you should be having more in the
way of fats actually so what are the
other ways of doing that where you can
do high-intensity interval training for
example you could have an intermittent
fasting time restricted feeding I
mentioned quercetin which is a
plant-based nutrient that you can get
from a number of plant foods and also in
supplement form even jumping in the
ocean and having a cold plunge is
another way of doing it having a massage
that there's so many ways of activating
the mitochondria that you don't have to
do a ketogenic diet to do that so it's
just about kind of helping people
understand why they got a benefit and
how else could they do so without
risking their long-term health I like
that answer
let's open it up I want to hear from all
of you guys and what you want to hear
from joma joma thank you very much for
what you do by the way it's it's we need
more doctors like that my question is
around the controversy right now with
soy and it's connection to estrogen
production and we seem to get a lot of
women that are backing away from soy
products because of that what's your
take on on that so I think that soy is
solely misrepresented soy has been shown
in studies to improve menopausal
flushing and in a number of different
mechanisms so you've got the you've got
it does contain phytoestrogens but
you've got the Alpha and the beta issue
Jim receptors in the body and the alpha
ishutin receptors tend to be on the
breast and in the uterus and the beta
ones tend to be on the bone and the
beauty of soy products is that they bind
preferentially to the beta Eastridge in
receptors the one on the bone so that
they're proven to be quite good for bone
health and whereas when you've got
mammalian equivalent estrogens so for
example from
milk they're going to bind
preferentially to the alpha issue to
receptors to the breast and the uterus
which would then therefore increase risk
potentially of abnormal growths in those
areas so I think if you're worried about
phytoestrogens
you probably need to drink less beer
because the the most potent fighter
estrogen is in hops so if a man's worry
about getting man boobs he should stick
a stick away from the beer and make a
Karen having as much soy as he is he
once although I would say organic soy is
always best you're welcome
all right thanks to a super specific
question I saw I recently had I mean I
guess just to me I went plant-based
about 1516 months ago and I didn't have
a recent blood test before that to
compare but when I had this one my white
blood cell counts were really low so
like it was a three and I remember what
the scale was I think it's in the
thousands
well my was like 3,000 or something so
I'm just curious if you've seen other
plant-based patients who have like a low
white blood cell count or anything I
could do to kind of counteract that in
in diet or supplement what's interesting
is that if you're feeling generally well
you may not need to counteract that
because it may just be that your body is
not producing that many white cells
because it doesn't have much
inflammation or infection to be dealing
with at the moment
so I can't go into specifics for your
medical history but what I would say is
get it checked again so that you can
monitor it over time and if you're
feeling generally well and it's just
slightly at the lower end of normal or
slightly under the lower end of what
most of the people the population have
it's not actually necessarily a problem
because you're not going to be making so
many white cells or neutrophils if you
don't have so much inflammation and
oxidative stress in your body yeah hey
Jemma I have quite a few friends who are
dealing with ulcerative colitis and
Crohn's and one in particular who's got
his tried every diet every is on
steroids all the time
all of the stuff they normally you know
tell people all sort of quite us to do
um and she feels best when she's eating
a high very high protein diet with very
little good carbohydrates and all of
that you know normal kind of autoimmune
protocol diet type thing my question for
you is she did try an Ayurvedic diet for
about a five day period and said that
she felt worse on it then you know on
her high protein autoimmune protocol
diet what are your thoughts on someone
with ulcerative colitis and what they
should do and if if there's a way to do
it more plant-based yeah yeah that's my
question thank you really roundabout
okay thank you I do really feel for your
friend because she's obviously suffering
hugely and all she of colitis and
Crohn's disease are hugely on the rise
over the last 50 years much more so even
in the last 10 20 years and a lot of
that is around our gut health and leaky
tight junctions of the gut and issues
around pesticide use and ultra-processed
foods and also actually saturated fat
sometimes can also contribute to
disruption of those tight junctions
antibiotics pesticides these are all
things that have contributed potentially
to issues so it's going to be a long
road probably of healing and I can't
give specific advice for her about which
diet she tried in which ones are useful
but what I would say is that giving the
gut arrest is the nut is always in the
number one strategy and you're
immediately trying to heal it trying to
seal up those tight junctions is number
two and there's multiple ways that I've
already mentioned that we can attempt to
do that and for long-term health and
people with ulcerative colitis and
Crohn's disease a whole food plant-based
diet is tremendously effective and she
might be interested to read the work of
dr. Alan Desmond he's a good friend of
mine he's a gastroenterologist and he's
talked a lot about the benefits of whole
food plant-based diets and he is a
specialist in flemish about disorders
like Crohn's disease and ulcerative
colitis he's on instagramers Devon got
doctor and and he got dr. B as well will
and he
is an American gastroenterologist and he
again talks in great detail about some
of the benefits of plant-based nutrition
for these inflammatory bowel diseases
but it's it's a it's a it's a slow road
and she has to heal the gut first or
foremost so yeah so those are some good
resources for her to have a look at I
would also suggest checking out dr.
Robin shut can you I did a podcast with
several years ago and has written a
couple of books on this but she's
amazing as well fantastic yeah thank you
I just wonder what your opinion is on
b12 so b12 is an essential vitamin we we
use it for among many things breaking
down home a system which is an
inflammatory protein we also use b6 or
folate for that b12 comes from microbes
in the soil and so if you have a whole
food plant-based diet with unwashed
vegetables and untreated water in the
middle of nowhere then you were going to
probably get plenty of b12 you could
also make it if you have optimal
microbes within your gut
they will make b12 for you which is
quite wonderful however if you have poor
gut health or you're living in a sterile
environment where you're washing your
fruits or veggies or you're drinking
treated water you may find over time
that you'll become b12 deplete in which
case a simple supplement is all that you
need and what's interesting is if you're
eating a lot of fatty farmed animals
they will also be receiving b12
supplementation in their corn which you
then just eat through their muscles
because they've been supplemented so in
a sense you're you know you're cutting
out the middle cow by doing that so
those are my thoughts on v12 also
another point to make many meat-eaters
are b12 deficient especially if you're
over the age of 50 if you're taking a
proton pump inhibitor which is a really
common kind of antacid medication if
you're on metformin which is the
Communist diabetes medication if you
have an autoimmune disease and again
you're going to be far less likely to be
absorbing the b12 from your animal
products so anyone over the age of 50
whatever their diet may need to just get
their b12 checked to make sure that it's
optimal
you know two little follow-up questions
on that one of the things that I have to
field or that I hear all the time is
well a plant-based diet can't be a great
diet if it's lacking in this one thing
that you have to supplement with it so
it just gets discounted right yeah it's
unfortunate because when you look at the
nutrient density of different diet types
what you find is that nutria terian
approaches whole food plant-based
approaches and simple plant-based diets
are number one two and three in terms of
nutrient density and then you have you
know things like paleo maybe a little
bit lower down the list and you've got
keto a little bit lower down than that
because you're gonna get folate
deficiency and other sort of mineral
deficiencies using that kind of diet so
it's the most nutrient dense way of
eating
but yes b12 is one of the few caveats
but as I say many animals in the wild
don't get b12 deficiency because they're
living in accordance with nature and I
think that's what we need to do far more
of now and in the future the dirt
basically the second little cleanup
follow-up thing on that is there's two
kinds of commercially available b12
supplements right there's
methylcobalamin and why yes I would say
methyl cobalamin is much better because
it's more bioavailable you haven't got
to do the methylation within your body
and some people have a methylation sort
of deficit genetically which means that
they're less able to make that
conversion so I mean in the UK there's a
methyl cobalamin spray that's available
which I love because it's absorbing
sublingually aren't you know through the
tongue which is my favorite which is
what I like to tell people to use but
you'll have to have a look online and
see what's available to you but methyl
cobalamin is my preferred version and
what about b12 shots well it could be it
depends on your levels really I mean if
you if you're feeling well and you've
got massively high b12 levels because
you store it for up to five years so if
you're getting a b12 shot every month
and you're probably going to be
drastically over overdosing on v12 so I
don't I don't think it's necessary
unless you have obvious gut issues or
malabsorption issues or methylation
issues that you've already had to look
into with your physician on
missed ya who's next
I have blank hello - hi um you and your
husband obviously are both eating a
plant-based diet and I was curious how
you decided to approach it with your
children and having those kinds of
conversations both Room regards to
health but also like getting them to eat
it yeah I know so we are really lucky
because so our two children at the
moment of 7 and 4 and our youngest you
know he just enjoys what we make at home
he hasn't really put much thought into
it he just loves the food that we give
him so that's you know that's quite easy
I imagine that that might get more
challenging as he gets older our
youngest he's he's an interesting soul
because he was more into the
compassionate side of things from a
young age so he was the person that
encouraged me to stop eating chickens a
long time ago he said so we went to the
farm and he was picking out eggs and and
he said to me mummy well where do we em
you know what do we eat when we eat a
chicken we know we eat their muscles I
kind of try to flex my mini bicep and
show him my what am us all look like a
so that's what we eat and he said no
well how do we get it I thought no you
only little I have to tell you so I have
to be honest with him I said well we you
know the animal is killed so how how do
we kill it no I don't actually know I
said well maybe we shoot it or stun it
or maybe a knife I was not obviously
prepared for this conversation and the
look on his face I just thought okay you
know what we don't have to read this so
he he had autonomy in that decision
actually which really helped him because
then he became quite passionate about
not eating animals from that point
onwards and perhaps more so than myself
thank you very much into it and this is
pre richard running marathon yeah so
yeah
buried the lede here because his his
three-year-old inquisitive mind at the
time no so but it can be a challenge
especially if they're used to things but
then in a sense that's true of any kind
of healthful diet change because kids
love sugar and you know if they're
eating a lot of stuff that's kind of
junk food then that's always going to be
a challenge whatever you're trying to
give them so get them involved in the
kitchen get them involved in making
recipes and make it fun I'd also say
simple things like sitting down together
as a family to make it a special
occasion especially as they get as they
get a little bit older they might like
to have maybe a little can but with
dinner if they're not gonna reach
forward and grab the flame he was I
think youngest is two isn't she yeah so
let them get messy let them get involved
and you know make it fun and not too
much pressure if they don't want to eat
it that day then they don't have to and
then maybe they get a little bit hungry
and that's a shame but then the next day
they're going to really love the dinner
but I have made a Vimeo series with
plant-based news on raising children
with a plant-based diet and I've also
done some podcasts on that so if you
call my website gemiini mancom you'll be
able to see quite a lot of resources
around children and cookbook
recommendations and ideas and a variety
of resources around pregnancy and
raising children with the plant-based
diet and just to flush that out a little
bit further you know what is what is
your response when someone comes to you
and says listen I'm really attracted to
this plant-based lifestyle but like I'm
terrified of you know raising young
children on it I'm afraid they're gonna
be deficient in something yeah and
that's super common because people only
want the best for their kids and they
hear these scare stories and I try to
reassure them that actually evidence
shows that plant-based kids are
generally much much healthier than their
omnivorous counterparts there's less in
terms of chronic respiratory infections
allergies asthma eczema and so you know
they be reducing their short-term risk
of allergies and recurrent infections
and they'll be reducing their long-term
risk of heart disease in cancer so
overall it has to be
thing there's not many scientific
studies on raising children plant-based
although I I did read one in the
American Journal of Clinical Nutrition
that was done British children and back
in the seventies and eighties which is
really interesting because there weren't
that many vegan children back then and
they certainly didn't have all kinds of
terrible seitan you know yeah who knows
what they were eating my goodness must
have been fruits and vegetables and
grains you know pretty good stuff
overall so what they discovered was that
this group I think they managed to they
managed to gather around 60 plant-based
kids and they followed them for 13 years
some of them pre-pregnancy some of them
up to of teenage years and what they
discovered was that they were actually
doing tremendously well this is before
they didn't necessarily use any
supplementation they didn't have any of
the fortified milk so any of that stuff
and what they found was that they
actually comparing them to their own
Everest counterparts they had a far
superior nutritional profile and there
were two there was they were slightly
lower in their calcium scores but wasn't
significant in terms of their health and
they were lower in terms of their
saturated fat exposure but every other
nutrient and mineral they exceeded and
we're doing exceptionally well so the
researchers actually it was quite funny
reading the study because the
researchers were actually saying you
know these these parents receive a lot
of discrimination in the communities but
actually looking at the data the kids
doing brilliantly mm-hmm and is there
anything in particular that pregnancy
demands or requires in terms of
supplementation or something to be aware
of if if a pregnant expecting mother is
on a plant-based diet what's interesting
about plant-based diets and pregnancy is
that they're already excluding a lot of
the things that the pregnant women are
told to minimize so for example pregnant
women are told in the guidelines to
minimize their exposure to fish because
of the heavy metals dioxins PCBs and all
of the pollution from ocean fish and so
they're going to be excluding those
they're going to be excluding eggs and
Salmonella risk they're going to be
excluding and dairy cheese's and
Listeria risk so they're actually doing
pretty well in terms of benefiting the
baby
in terms of things that they might want
to look at I would always suggest a
general supplement for every pregnant
women just to be on the safe side I
would recommend iodine because many many
areas of the UK and in the US are going
to be and the soil is going to be iodine
deficient and it's quite hard to get
your quota of iodine which which it
should hopefully be in the multivitamin
but that's one of the main things and
EPA DHA supplements I like to recommend
there's no study data to suggest it's
worth doing but we can see that it's
beneficial for brain health and heart
health and so when you're making a new
human why not get an optimal amount so
yeah I'd say algae oil supplementation
and your multivitamin which must include
things like iron and iodine what about
iodine iodine so it's interesting
actually vitamins the vitamins yes sorry
[Laughter]
yes what's interesting is in the UK
there's this condition called Lancashire
neck where people used to get these
massive thyroid graters because they had
iodine deficiency from a lack of the
mineral in the soil nowadays there's
summer supplement there's some
supplementation and also in dairy they
use iodine to sterilize the milk vats so
that's why a lot of people can get
iodine a few dairy if you don't want to
get your iodine that way then you can
take a supplement or you can have
organic nutrient rich fruits and
vegetables or and you can nibble on nori
sheets actually my kids love those as a
snack I don't know if you tried to buy
those because you know you can make
sushi out of those nice nori sheets
thanks a very iodine rich yeah doesn't
milk to a body good I mean there's a lot
of like listen to be you know very
compassionate about this argument like
no parent wants to you know do the wrong
thing by their child and there's this
idea that you need dairy for sports for
strong bones and you know who wants to
raise a child with brittle but you do
feel terrible right so that whether it's
myth or fact and I'm interested in how
you you know your your thoughts on this
it is pervasive and it's very very
strong and so overcoming that you know
presumption of truth is
very difficult yes it is and I think in
Western European societies people relied
on dairy for a long time because when
you're going through a stage where in
human evolution we've got nutritional
scarcity you're gonna want to be able to
make sure you can get nutrition from any
source possible which would include the
milk of a cow you know and you're in
your town or village you had a cow you'd
milk it you get some nutrients that's
fine I think nowadays we've become
acutely aware that milk isn't what it
used to be the cows are kept in a very
cramped and difficult conditions which
means that they usually receive
antibiotics which will often then be in
the milk they're raised to be pregnant
whilst also lactating which would
increase their hormone profile which is
not great in terms of long-term health
you'd be producing igf-1 insulin-like
growth factor-1 when you drink the milk
which has been strongly associated with
increased cancer risk and what's
interesting is people are always talking
about bone health and how important it
is I haven't read a single study to show
increased bone mineral density with
increased milk consumption and I've read
maybe two or three studies to say that
actually the opposite is probably true
there was one from Sweden and a hundred
thousand people followed over 20 years
they looked at their milk consumption
and they realized that over time there
was actually increased fracture fracture
risk in women and increased mortality
risk for men and women the more milk
they consumed and so trying to
understand the mechanism behind that you
can't necessarily get the mechanism
through the epidemiological data but you
can have a guess that it could be
related to the galactose content because
I didn't see the same association with
yogurt because that the lactose was
partially fermented and but what's
interesting about galactose again is
that researchers often use DK d
galactose to induce cellular aging in
the animals that they test and so you
think well if you're giving something
something that's specific from dairy
that will then age the lab animal
prematurely do you really want to be you
know drinking that every day in your
coffee not really and also actually on
the topic of coffee when you have dairy
when you have cow's milk with the coffee
and we can't fill out some of the
phytonutrients in it so it's probably
best to be avoided in your coffee as
well but yeah I mean there's loads of
there's loads of controversy around it
but I think just trying
get back to basics look at the data look
at the mechanisms by which potential
harm could be caused and hopefully you
get to the truth of the matter and it's
interesting because I think you had
Volta long go on as a guest a while back
and he's a longevity researcher and what
he discovered through the mTOR pathway
was that there's three main mechanisms
of cellular aging you've got excess
leucine excess refined sugar and excess
calories in general so if you're going
to be having a lot of extra calories
then that's not great for cellular aging
if you're going to be having refined
sugar from processed foods and junk
foods that's not great but also excess
leucine which is primarily from animal
products will also age you prematurely
so there's a number of reasons why dairy
might not be a good idea and also the
case in proteins they've been linked to
oxidative stress and inflammation as
well there's links to prostate cancer
specifically there's links to other
hormone-dependent cancers breast cancer
ovarian cancer so yeah I'm hoping that
not to be all doom and gloom but I'm
hoping that at least it will be a
reassurance for any parent out there
that that may be deciding not to give
their child dairy that it can actually
be a really good decision I agree with
you the dairy is not good but how do I
increase my calcium without taking a
supplement supplement can be bad for you
too I think probably the main things for
you to focus on would be your green
leafy vegetables your sources of seeds
and nuts and things like tahini actually
is a very good calcium source and tahini
it's and it's like a spread that you
make from a sesame seeds and dried
fruits are really good for that as well
but more than anything else weight
bearing exercise would be really
beneficial yeah weight bearing exercise
is a really good one so well done you're
doing you're doing a lot of the right
stuff but mainly as I say seeds dried
fruits and leafy greens they the calcium
and leafy greens is more bioavailable on
the whole so I think 56% bioavailability
compared to 32% or something around
those lines between things like broccoli
and dairy so you're going to be able to
absorb more of it as long as you keep
eating lots of those delicious whole
plant foods so vitamin D is crucial for
bone health and we make most of it
through sunlight exposure on us and it's
actually a hormone many people have
vitamin vitamin D deficient I want you
to keep saying it your way vitamin D so
many people have a deficiency in vitamin
D and it's hard because we're not living
the same lives that we used to we're not
out in the Sun showing very much so I
would recommend a supplement from that
point of view yes just to make sure that
you're optimized and some people are not
very good at making their vitamin D from
sunlight exposure so again checking your
levels making sure they're optimized and
then taking that as a supplement if
necessary would be my best advice for
that and vitamin D is not a vegan
omnivore thing I mean the the levels of
vitamin D deficiency across population
in general is quite high exactly and not
as I say 90% through is through the skin
so even if you're having loads of things
like mushrooms that have been fortified
through sunlight and fortified nut milks
and things like that it's only 10% of
your of your requirement 90% through the
skin so try and get outside in nature of
course that's most important thing but
other than that then yeah lots of them
getting the test done dimensionally
you've got a supplement if you need to I
just realized something I didn't go
through the rest of my special gloves
acronym about all the things that we
need to do we should because I had a
reminder with regard to that so oh for
organic v for veggies so for the
exercise component then I would say it's
so important to just get outside but
whatever you can manage we've got dr.
Zack Bush tomorrow and he's going to
talk about all sorts of things I'm sure
but on my website I've got a link to his
4-minute nitric oxide workout which I
think it's absolutely fantastic because
what it does is it just gives you a four
minute of intense but also very
achievable exercise that will kind of
you know activate your body and get you
moving but getting outside in nature as
part of that exercise is really
really beneficial you're going to be
breathing in all sorts of beneficial
microbes forest bathing the Japanese do
that and there's a study I read recently
which shows that that that is really
beneficial for improving our immune
system boosting again IgA levels so
getting outside breathing in that fresh
air and staying active is crucial and
asleep and that might be a little bit of
an issue for you rich but we've got to
try and get a good night's sleep
and for for overall health and seven to
eight hours if possible trying to keep a
regular sleep pattern it is really good
you can't really catch up on lost sleep
and unfortunately a lot of the study
data shows that people who stay up too
late to in the week I think are just
lying in the weekend it doesn't work it
doesn't it doesn't do the same job
metabolically so trying to stay regular
with the sleep patterns reducing blue
light in the evenings so that you can
get your serotonin turning into
melatonin which will then improve your
sleep patterns is also crucial so yeah
that was my that was my little acronym
love's yeah I just want to thank rich
and Mo for what you're doing it's
fantastic last February I hadn't
listened to Rich's podcasts at this
stage but I give pet public like two
talks on how to rewire your brain etc
and people had asked me about nutrition
and I honestly believed at that point
before I start this podcast that if you
did everything in moderation you're
going to be okay and that's what I was
doing and then my lab discovered sugar
is as addictive as alcohol and nicotine
so my question is really about sugar and
what you tell people but I basically got
diagnosed in February of last year with
kind of a mild form of Hashimoto's
hypothyroidism which I didn't expect to
ever have because I was exercising you
know blah blah blah and and then for
some unknown reason I got to Rich's
podcast I went plant-based and then I
did blood tests in February August and
December of last year I did it the same
lab the same time fasting you know to
make sure I kept all the variables as
tight as I could and my all my numbers
went down not just my
TSH and my t3 t4 and my antibodies for
the diagnosis but also my triglycerides
my LDL and my HDL reversed in exactly a
better direction even though I was kind
of in range sort of for all those anyway
and I won't go into the rest of how it
made me feel
but anyway so on the sugar side that was
really my question to you because I want
to just thank you for that saving me for
getting drugs my doctor was like how did
you do that but on the sugar side so
what we've shown is that sugar changes
the brain the prefrontal cortex and
activates the amygdala the emotional
part of the brain in exactly the same
way that alcohol does and most of the
world the Western world is consuming
three times the recommended World Health
Organization levels of sugar and they
don't even know they are and what as you
know you've seen probably all of that
research around fructose activating the
visceral fat cells that's where the
energy stored and then it doesn't
activate gorilla and leptin and that's
what make people over consume other food
because it doesn't make you feel hungry
right you've I mean you never feel
satisfied when you eat too much sugar so
I'm just interested in your take on what
your tell you'll pay I know you'll be
really well read on that yeah so I tell
my patients that sugar is not the enemy
as long as they're getting it from a
whole source they were wired to we're
wired to respond to sugar and the sugar
from fruits in its whole natural form
which also contains the phytonutrients
the antioxidants the soluble and
insoluble fibers these are all crucial
for for being able to absorb the sugar
in that in the way that it's intended
and you're right you know the brain
responds to sugar in the same way that
it responds to other things that you can
you know find addictive but it's
different with whole fruit and I think
if we go back to nature we go back to
basics people understand that you know
okay if I'm going to make fruit the
cornerstone of my sugar intake then
that's only going to be a good thing and
it does it certainly reduces the
problems like fatty liver that fructose
has been associated with so I would
strongly recommend fruit in its whole
natural form as a general advice for
anyone that's going on a healthy
plant-based diet what about smoothies
and juicing
reducing will depend on your
pre-existing medical conditions so for
example say you're a type 2 diabetic and
you've only just discovered the
plant-based lifestyle I don't think it's
a good idea to have a fruit heavy
smoothie because you're going to still
be quite interesting and resistant if
you're generally healthy and fit and
well then I don't see there being too
much of an issue but it's just it's
again it's that fast sugar rush isn't it
so you you're taking a extra fiber
especially if you're juicing so yeah I'd
say Whole Foods in its natural form if
you're suffering from any kind of
condition related to insulin resistance
like polycystic ovarian syndrome or
gestational diabetes or type 2 diabetes
and yeah sticking with the the vegetable
based smoothies would probably be a
better choice for those people yeah yeah
I'm just wondering in your patients or
studies if you've seen any difference in
testosterone levels and especially men
like over 40's you know we're supposed
to be decreasing like the difference
between plant-based or non plant-based
diets yeah testosterone levels seem to
be better and vegans actually which is
rather nice and we're still waiting for
the game changes to come out but I just
not out yet is it now he's still not out
yet but they did a fantastic study on on
young males who didn't have a reptile
dysfunction and there were just young
healthy guys and they wanted to measure
the the strength and integrity of their
erections overnight and so what they did
was turn Judah T yes and what they
discovered in these young men who didn't
have any kind of a reptile dysfunction
was with that when they gave them a
burrito based on on them beans versus a
burrito based on meat
they had significantly firmer and more
frequent erections than the men who'd
had their meat burritos so I'd say not
only is it likely that your testosterone
levels will go up if you have a healthy
plant-based diet but your virility would
also rise the soreness isn't that that's
more of a blood flow thing though is
that's a strange rhythm yeah yeah it's
not really where I was going with that
but that's like you don't need to worry
wheel yeah for real like as men age up
we start to get concerned like our
testosterone levels are being part of
that is like they okay they're gonna dip
and I personally know a lot of men who
are taking testosterone replacement
therapy yeah it comes up in conversation
with guy friends like hey are you doing
that like how is that working should I
do that should I not do that what are
the dangers what are the risks what is
the implications of diet on those levels
so I mean in terms of diet we use
dietary we use cholesterol to as a
backbone for most of the hormone all of
the hormones we make in our body so
cholesterol is the backbone for
testosterone and estrogen and cortisol
and pretty much every hormone but we
make plenty of that we make we're very
good cholesterol conservers and we're
very good cholesterol makers so we don't
need any extra dietary cholesterol to be
able to make those hormone backbones and
but when you're on a whole food
plant-based diet it means that you're
not overusing and the hormones that
already in your system so having extra
dietary fiber means that you're not kind
of reabsorbing and unnecessary extra
hormones which is quite good for things
like Ystad in excess or testosterone
excess but in terms of deficiency I've
never seen anybody on a healthy
plant-based diet have a testosterone
deficiency and in fact what's
interesting is I not to get into the
diet Wars of course but having watched
one of the carnivore proponents talk
about his own blood profile he actually
had a low testosterone on his carnivore
diet so I think the opposite is true I
think you don't really don't need to
worry about your testosterone levels
yeah have you seen the effects of a
plant-based fat diet on dementia yes and
I'd recommend that you look into the
work of dr. Shirazi and Shirazi on that
because they are real trailblazers in
with regard to long-term health and
dementia rates and plant-based diets so
yeah it does seem to help a lot and
there may be multiple mechanisms for
that
again getting back to gut health and why
and where the beta-amyloid plaques build
up it's possible that the saturated fats
in the diet can disrupt the tight
junctions of the guts which allowed the
lipopolysaccharides or LPS from the gut
bacterial cell membranes to go inside
the bloodstream which then increases
inflammation oxidative stress and then
potential beta amyloid plaque formation
the same so so basically yes there's
quite a few mechanisms where it could be
helpful it's not the only thing that's
helpful so making sure that you getting
a good amount of sleep for example is
crucial in reducing dementia risk yeah
generally things like well-being and
staying active so there's a number of
things but a plant-based diet can
definitely be helpful and I'll check out
their work if you're interested to know
more just to echo Gemma on that
conventional wisdom is essentially that
that when it comes to Alzheimer's and
dementia there's just not that much that
that that can that can be done right
but the sure's days Dean and Aisha
they're a married couple who have a lab
at Loma Linda University they're having
some pretty remarkable success treating
a population of patients with diet and
lifestyle protocols and a plant-based
diet as part of that so I would
definitely look into their work I did a
podcast with them you can find it in the
archive and they have a book called the
Alzheimer's solution that I would
suggest you check out I have a question
back on the vitamin D do you still get
vitamin D if you were sunblock like the
foundation and the question is I always
am concerned about using sunblock but
then I also want to get the the vitamin
D so I I generally will go out in the
Sun and not have sunblock and then
everyone's freaking out like oh you're
gonna get skin cancer and I'm like well
I feel like sunblock is cancer you know
like a chemical that what may cause
cancer down the line or I can get
the Sun so I'm choosing that when I
guess yeah
sunblock so you're not gonna be able to
get vitamin D if you wear sunblock and I
would suggest sensible sunlight exposure
as being the best solution for this so
making sure that you go out in the Sun
at a time at which your shadow is
shorter than your body then you'll be
able to more efficiently make vitamin D
through sunlight exposure but also
become aware of when your skin is
starting to you know feel sensitive to
that sun exposure and then know then you
get into your long Cotton's and cover up
that would be my basic advice I don't
think it's healthy to to be wearing some
sunblock all the time so yeah that would
be my best solution is to is to just
exercise judicious sunlight exposure has
there been any formal Studies on the
plant-based diet and how it affects
mental health and mood disorder yes they
have so interestingly the smiles child
came out in 2017 which showed that a
modified Mediterranean diet was was
being used as a as a therapy for
depression and what they found was this
was a diet that was very heavy in
vegetables and grains and fruit and they
still had a little bit of fish and dairy
in that diet but it was far more
plant-based than not and what they
discovered was that in the intervention
group with the diet alone they had a
third remission rate in people with mild
to moderate depression and in the group
that just had social support there was I
think it was an 8% remission rate so
that there was a very dramatic
difference between the two and there was
a study done in the US on 300 people
looking at at their well-being and
anxiety scores so what they did was it
was a basic workplace intervention all
they did was they told people look you
can have a plant-based meal if you like
there's the work canteen you can choose
the plant-based option and here's a
little bit of Education around
plant-based eating and why it might be
good for you so the people that were
educated on plant-based diets decided to
on the whole probably eat the
plant-based optional though they didn't
monitor that but what they did monitor
was their cholesterol levels there
their weight and their well-being
schools productivity schools depression
schools and what was fascinating was
that with no other intervention they
were able to reduce their weight reduce
their lipid profiles improve their
diabetes if they had it but also
crucially improve their mental health
well-being and productivity at work
which is I think is really interesting
because a plant-based diet seems to be
quite beneficial than a number of levels
you know you've got the extra fiber so
you fibers not just useful for bulking
up your diet and making sure that you
don't get diverticular disease or
varicose veins or appendicitis it's
actually useful on a microbiome level
because what you're doing is you're
providing fantastic short chain fatty
acids for your microbes to digest and
then your microbes do all the work for
you they make serotonin for you they
modulate dopamine levels and that's
crucial for mental health you know if
you're giving an antidepressant all
you're really doing is stopping the
serotonin from being real you know taken
up again by the body and you're stopping
it yourself from absorbing too much of
it but the beauty of a plant-based diet
is that your gut microbes are able to
make so much more serotonin about 70 80
percent so the serotonin production
happens in the gut lining itself so it's
really important for mental health to
have a fruit and veg high diet and
obviously I would promote organic fruit
and vegetables over non-organic because
again you've got the beneficial effect
of not having those tight junctions of
the gut being disturbed and that can
also increase risk of depression there's
a couple of studies on aspartame and
artificial sweeteners as well on people
who already have mental health problems
and there seem to be quite a strong
association with worsening of those
mental health problems with aspartame
and other artificial sweeteners which is
something to consider because if you're
having a fizzy drink with an artificial
sweetener you might be aware to stop it
but they're actually contained in a lot
of different foods that you might not
expect including things like chewing gum
so that's something else to be aware of
as well but there's loads of mental
health resources if you want to look on
my website and I've actually got a list
of many studies to show the improvements
in mental health with a plant-based diet
so check that out as well and can I just
add Timothy all the research showing
about intermittent fast
think promoting brain plasticity so
there's extensive research come out in
the last year or two that's showing that
the intermittent you know the sixteen
eight or whatever it is I think you had
this on your podcast too but basically
the scientists have shown that it you
get an increase in brain plasticity hmm
and as you strengthen the front part of
your brain which is where impulse
control and executive functions sit that
gives you top-down control over the
emotional part of the brain which is
where anxiety fear and all of these
other things sit so I think intermittent
fasting also has a lot of value to in
terms of brain plasticity in terms of
dementia and mental health problems
because as you strengthen your brain
you're going to be getting more layers
in the onion so to speak so you have
less to come off as you get older that's
so interesting because when I clamp down
on impulse control then I start having
all kinds of emotional problems that's
because you're not getting enough sleep
[ __ ] your amygdala is on fire right
okay this thing also the brain needs an
incredible large amount of blood flow
and as you're correcting with plant base
and improving people's blood pressure
cholesterol plaques and tangles and all
the other stuff that's happening because
everything's going to an end
in the sense there and you're increasing
telomeres as well and telomerase
activity then you're getting more ATP
more mitochondria active inside the
brain cells which require almost all of
your energy too and that's going to help
with dementia or depression all sorts of
things - thank you that's wonderful hey
Jenna thank you has been great just
wondering what your thoughts on
probiotics are that I mean for a while
it was all about probiotics and now it
seems yeah sort of be leveling out so
microbial research is I think still in
its relative infancy and so we jump on
the bandwagon of taking lots of
probiotics because we think we'll be got
to get the good stuff in and get rid of
the bad stuff but to my mind the most
important thing is to have a varied
healthy
Nicke plant-based diet in terms of being
able to feed beneficial gut microbes
fermented foods are really useful
they're kind of like the cavalry that
comes in but then you know they also
leave again with your stools most most
commonly so in order to get those
beneficial microbes to stay within the
gut where they're needed to stay within
the large intestine you can O be having
to feed them dietary fiber in the form
of fruits vegetables whole grains and
beans that is the cornerstone of Health
when you've had a course of antibiotics
you're going to have to think a bit more
carefully around making sure that you
aim to regenerate those lost bugs
because that's a little bit like a
nuclear bomb to your beneficial microbes
and so it may be beneficial then to have
a short course of probiotics but it's
more important to restore gut health
through fruits and vegetables organic
and yeah I think also restore got health
is a really good supplement for that
which is made by dr. Zack Bush I also
think yes we're kind of at the emergent
you know stage of better understanding
this field but there's also a lot of
misinformation out there and I think
there's this idea that hey I just take
my probiotic and so I'm good and the
truth is is that the vast majority of
the probiotic products that are out
there are you know for the most part
like garbage and they're very limited in
their strains and I think because of
antibiotic use in the way that
antibiotics are used in our food system
matched with the decline in biodiversity
of you know our overall ecosystem and
the way our foods are you know farmed
that it is a real issue and I think we
need to learn a little bit more about
how to best deal with this because I
think there are deficiencies that need
to be addressed I'm putting a podcast up
soon with it I did an interview with the
founders of this new company called seed
who's kind of they're kind of on the
cutting edge of this and there's a lot
of great information in that
conversation that might be helpful to
you yeah and also when you're taking a
lot of probiotics for a long time you're
actually reducing your diversity of
microbes which is not good for long-term
health so yeah if you're gonna try and
do it then there may be
pick one that has the you know the
largest diversity for the shortest time
but fruits and vegetables in organic is
probably the best way forward getting
your fiber in I just wondered if there's
anybody that since this podcast that is
thinking okay this sounds great but how
do I start what do you say to your
patients when they say great doctor what
do I do for breakfast lunch dinner
tomorrow how do I start yeah so yeah
good question thank you so I find their
motivation I find their why and if
they've got a good motivation then I
start simple I say okay so what do you
normally eat for breakfast what do you
normally eat for lunch what do you
normally for dinner and then I help them
go through some simple swaps things that
wouldn't necessarily taste identical but
things that they could make just as
easily so for example porridge is always
a great choice for breakfast and you can
mix in some fabulous flax seeds or chia
seeds we know that flax seeds and
studies have been shown to dramatically
reduce blood pressure in some people so
one or two tablespoons mixed in is
really great
can I sorry sorry is it important that
those flax seeds are ground them if
they're not ground yeah so they're
better ground but then the issue with
ground is you've got to make sure that
you eat them quickly because then they
are less able to stay kind of
nutritionally adequate so by them ground
and use them quick or buy them whole and
grind them yourself and know that the
nutrients will stay anyway so not to
overcomplicate things
porridge seeds berries you can have
wholemeal bread with your nut butters
you can have a healthy muesli or granola
with your nut milks give us some basic
ideas for breakfast then again depending
on what they like to eat for lunch
perhaps a simple plant-based burrito or
maybe they you know they might like a
tofu scramble instead of an egg Mayo it
really depends on what they normally eat
but then dinner say for example they
like a chicken curry then maybe make a
chickpea curry instead if they're a
spaghetti bolognaise fan maybe go for a
lentil Bolognese
one pot lentil Bolognese is so easy
takes 15 minutes and you can you know
batch cook so essentially find out what
they like and give them options that
they can make that are just as good but
healthy too and yeah that would be my
top tip if people want more information
about recipes and advice then they can
go to my website or my Instagram plant
power doctor to find out more with a
little @ symbol with a little basically
there's so much about there's so much
more to health than what we put on our
plate but what we do put on our plate if
we can make it healthy and predominantly
plant-based you're really onto a winner
and then that's where you can look at
other aspects of health with far more
clarity yeah let me just I can't believe
that we've been going for two hours
protein has not been yet nobody so I
guess that's a testament to how well
versed all of you are in this but of
course the question where do you get
your protein does come up and one of the
responses that I'm starting to hear or
kind of statements that gets bandied
about is that animal protein is yes you
can you can eat a plant-based diet and
you can meet your protein needs but
plant protein is inferior to animal
protein so how do you feel that question
so I like to tell people that I used to
worry about protein - before I
researched it because I think that's the
first question that most people ask but
then I reassure them that you know
plants have protein because that's where
the animals get their protein from so
it's a fairly straightforward thing that
if you're the animal that you eat with
has eaten plants and then they got their
protein from those plants and in fact
people tend to eat twice as much protein
as they need and half as much fiber as
they need so the average plant-based
dieter will actually get twice as much
protein in their diets than they
actually physically need so it's
generally not concerned but also you got
a look at your protein package so what
else you taking in with your protein
and when you're having a meat heavy diet
then you're going to be getting some
protein obviously you're going to be
getting some omega-6 is predominantly if
you've got a factory farm down and
moreover omega-3s but you're also going
to be getting various carcinogens at the
same time so when you cook it what
happens when you cook the meats then
you've released heterocyclic amines
which are carcinogenic compounds and
when you when you grill it you still get
the same heterocyclic amines and it's
worse when you barbecue it but you can't
really escape it any kind of animal
protein when cooked will do this if it's
a processed meat then you're going to
get and the trustor compounds which are
also carcinogenic then you've got to
look at what your body does with it
you've got heme iron which people say
great you know you're gonna have more
bioavailable iron well that's true but
heme iron also oxidize is more readily
in the body which is associated with
inflammation and obviously not good for
long-term health and then what happens
when your gut microbes come into contact
with that meat well they're going to
want to digest the carnitine and in so
doing you've got gut microbes that
produce something called TMA which then
goes to the liver and makes TMAO
trimethylamine oxide which is a toxin
increases risk of heart disease that
worsens kidney failure it worsens heart
failure it's not a good thing to have in
the system so you've got a number of
mechanisms by which your animal protein
package might be doing more harm than
good and I haven't even mentioned the
igf-1 factor which I talked about
earlier so you're going to be making
more gf1 which is associated with
increased cancer risk what do you get in
your plant protein package well you get
the phytonutrients the antioxidants the
insoluble insoluble fiber you get all
this good stuff alongside it so yeah
look at the package as a whole and then
decide which one you're gonna have more
of on your plate and if someone's
looking to make a change but they're
scared of the you know all in like okay
you know I'm going I'm just gonna change
everything overnight like most people
don't let's be honest like that that's
not how change really is made for people
so if someone's listening to this and
they're they're intrigued and they're
you know feeling motivated to make a
change but they're trying to figure out
well what's the what's the first thing
that I should do like what's the most
important like if I have to it's too
overwhelming for me
all everything that you said I need time
but like tell me one thing I can do
tomorrow like what would be the first
most impactful change that that person
the most impactful thing would be to
think I'm gonna change I'm gonna I'm
gonna learn one new recipe this week one
new one new thing that I can learn how
to cook that I like that I can
incorporate into my life and then if you
do that every day every week for five
weeks you've pretty much got an entire
repertoire cuz people people kind of
stick with the same foods in and out day
after day so if you can make a promise
to yourself that you're gonna get
yourself a plant-based cookbook or even
better simply just go onto Google and go
healthy plant-based recipes and then
type in your favorite meal and see what
comes up and promise yourself that
you're gonna make that meal just that
one time see how it goes see if you like
it and then perhaps the next week you
might try an easy breakfast breakfast is
kind of easy because you don't have to
think too much about that as long as
you've got simple things like oats you
can make plant powered pancakes you can
make your porridge you can make your
granola and that's really
straightforward so that could be your
first plant-based meal and then you just
have to learn maybe a new recipe every
week or two and gradually sort of ease
yourself into it I mean there's no
pressure it's a it's a it's a diet of
abundance it's a lifestyle of abundance
and that's the thing that we need to
remember I think so many people are
caught up on thinking oh I've got to
stop eating this or that no you're going
to be incorporating an abundance of
beautiful fresh healthy foods into your
life and hopefully as you eat those
foods you're going to be able to really
get an experience of how delicious it is
and how much is nourishing your body
nourishing your mind nourishing your
soul and then you're gonna want to learn
a new meal the next week you can I want
to learn a new recipe the week after
that just take then then looking at it
from a perspective of lack and all the
things that you're gonna be removing
from your plate focus on the awesome
adventure of building in all these new
foods that you're not used to eating and
then second to that I think there's a
lot of wisdom in mastering one thing at
a time
you know for a lot of people it's like I
just can't imagine you know not putting
milk in my coffee or you know something
simple like that that you can change
like okay well I'm going to just master
almond milk in my coffee instead of
that and like do that for a couple weeks
until you feel good about that you could
make the next change exactly in fact
that's why I would encourage people to
do anyone that's listening right now if
you've been thinking about a plant-based
diet if you've been wondering about a
plant-based diet and you're not sure
what the first step to take is we've
obviously covered a lot of ground today
but this could be your chance to make
one change just one thing that you can
do tomorrow that could change your daily
habit and if you can keep doing that for
a few days and then maybe make one more
change that's the beginning of a new
reality for you so maybe have a think is
there one thing that you could do today
or tomorrow that would make a difference
to your daily routine that you could
commit to doing that you could maybe
tell your spouse about or maybe a friend
so that they can keep you accountable
and then start you off on your fantastic
abundant health journey that's so
inspiring you're very optimistic are you
truly that you know when I looked when I
kind of like take it take a look from
10,000 feet down on planet Earth it's
easy to to despair of how we're treating
the planet and to see the declining
health of our population there are tools
like we've just been talking about today
that can transform all of that that are
accessible and very doable and yet
sometimes I feel like I don't know are
we are we gonna win this war how do you
look at that I like to think of it as as
a journey of enlightenment for Humanity
rather than a war because otherwise it
does get kind of depressing but if we
think of it as a journey of
enlightenment we know instinctively that
staying close to nature is super
important for our health and for the
health of our children and we know
seeing that one species is dying every
20 minutes we know we're in the middle
of something serious and that something
has to be done but overwhelm is not the
emotion with which to face this hope and
gratitude and love are the emotions with
which to face this so stay positive make
a change for yourself
tell others about your change feel good
and hopefully the message will spray
mic drop cheer for Jemma Newman thank
you
beautiful yes what a delight you can
learn more about Jemma Jemma Newman calm
and at plant power dr. anything anywhere
else you want to direct people yeah so
the plant-based health professionals UK
are a great organization headed up by
dr. Shireen kasam and that also has a
great website and we do lots of events
we've got a great event coming up with
dr. Kim Williams former head of the
American College of Cardiology he's
going to be talking in London next month
and we've got the happy pair guys going
to be there as well and also Bosch
they've done a great plant-based
cookbook so please do come and join us
at that event that's where we'll be
we've got veg med coming up in October
which is a fantastic international
plant-based conference we've got dr.
Klapper speaking there I shall be
speaking there as well if anybody wants
to check that out they're still tickets
available for the public to come along
on the public day so please come and
check that out and yeah those are the
two things really so peace plants
[Music]
that was great right I thought she was
awesome the power of plants what else
can I tell you I've been banging this
drum for so long anyway
let Gemma know what you thought of
today's conversation you can hit her up
on twitter at dr jim gem dr Ge Ge and on
instagram at plant power dr. you can
learn more by reading her blog at gem
and newman dot-com and as always please
check out the show notes at rich
Worldcom on the episode page to take
your edification of today's episode
beyond the earbuds tons of resources and
links and stuff like that to learn more
about Gemma and plant-based nutrition
another reminder to go to meals
brushroll com2 check out our amazing
meal planner that we talked about in the
intro great reviews try it out for
yourself if you would like to support
the work we do here on the podcast a
couple simple ways to do that tell your
friends about it tell them about your
favorite episode talk to them about it
at the bar at the restaurant over family
dinner share the show on social media
take a screen grab put it up on
Instagram Twitter wherever Facebook tag
me sometimes I like to reshare that
stuff most importantly hit subscribe on
Apple podcasts on YouTube on Spotify on
Google podcasts wherever you listen to
this leave a review on Apple podcasts
leave a comment underneath the videos on
YouTube and you can support us on
patreon by going to rich roll com ford
slash donate i want to thank everybody
who helped put on the show today jason
camiolo for audio engineering production
shownotes interstitial music Blake
Curtis and Margo Lubin for videoing and
editing the podcast right now I'm with
Blake he's in the sound booth so he's
taking on some audio engineering tasks
today as well Jessica Miranda for
graphics Allie Rogers for her beautiful
photographs DK for advertiser
relationships and theme music is always
by analemma appreciate the love you guys
thank you for listening I do not take
your attention or your time for granted
and I'll see you back here in a couple
days with a very hotly anticipated
fantastic conversation with the amazing
the inspirational Rebecca rush yes the
girl power continues with Rebecca she's
amazing she's an adventure racer in
extraordinary
Mountain Bike champion endurance athlete
powerhouse until then eat more plants
people more fruit more veg peace out
[Music]